What if instead of shining brightly
for another 5 billion years,
the only star in our solar system turned
into a dark and cold remnant of black
dwarf.
How long would the earth last without
all the heat and light it gets from the
sun? And how would the sun
going dark change the universe.
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
our son turned into a black dwarf.
All stars have an expiration date.
They don't just fade to black.
Though stars like our sun don't have
enough mass to become a neutron star.
They end up expanding to red giants and
then shedding their outer layers until
only their core remains.
That's when they become white dwarfs.
White dwarfs don't have fusion
reactions fueling them up.
They gradually cooled down until
one day they become black dwarfs.
The thing is there are no black
dwarfs anywhere in the universe.
Black dwarves just having formed.
Yet you see,
white dwarfs may not produce any energy,
but they still have enough of it left to
keep them shining faintly for hundreds
of billions of years.
Given that the universe is
only 13.8 billion years old.
Even the oldest white dwarfs are still
glowing at temperatures of a few thousand
degrees. Calvin, in the case of our sun,
it will take another quadrillion years
for it to cool down and become a black
dwarf that's 1 million million
million million years from now.
Give or take a few millions.
Think humans will be around for that long.
Well, let's switch it up. What
if the Sun burnt out tomorrow?
I hope you have a good supply of
batteries on hand because the entire solar
system would be thrown into darkness,
put on a few sweaters because it would
become much colder to planetary speaking.
We're pretty spoiled here on earth with
all the heat and light provided by the
sun. We're able to make a comfortable
home on a rock hurtling through space at
110,000 kilometers per hour.
It's easy to forget that we're
just another speck in the universe,
but if the sun stopped burning,
it would be immediately evident that
we're just floating in space after the
first week without the sun's heat.
The earth surface temperature would drop
to zero degrees Celsius. After a year,
it would go down even more dropping to
a freezing cold minus 100 that is if the
sun turned into a black dwarf instantly,
which is unlikely.
Even for our hypothetical scenario,
realistically to become a black dwarf,
the son would have to go through all
stages of the stellar lifecycle from the
main sequence stars.
It is now the sun would expand into a
red giant fade out to a white dwarf state
and only then cool down to become a
black dwarf at the red giant stage.
It would bake the earth,
most likely swallowing it completely
along with Venus and mercury.
At least we wouldn't have to worry about
freezing to death once the sun shrank
to a black dwarf.
What about the rest of the planets?
The ones lucky enough to have evaded the
burning flames of the red giant? Well,
they've keep orbiting that remnant of
the sun as if nothing had happened.
Even though the sun would
shrink to the size of the earth,
it's mass would stay the same.
Meaning that its gravitational pull would
remain unchanged in the grand scale of
the universe. The death of the son
wouldn't change anything either.
The Sun would be just
another star to go dark,
too small and insignificant to make
the universe even a tiny bit darker.
But what if all the stars
died at the same time? Well,
that's a story for another.
What if.